a sólo 80 kilómetros de la frontera
polaca lviv es el principal punto de
tránsito para los que huyen hacia el
oeste de ucrania entre ellos esta
familia que dejó atrás a su padre y
esposo quien se quedó para luchar no
entendemos lo que está pasando el
mariupol es totalmente imprevisible allí
no hay red telefónica ni agua ni
electricidad
me siento perdida temo por mis
familiares y no sé cuál será nuestro
futuro se están utilizando salones
deportivos escuelas hospitales iglesias
y teatros para albergar a los
desplazados por detalle o esta noche
pasaron por aquí 64 personas es lo
máximo que podemos acomodar porque sólo
hay una ducha el teatro no está adaptado
para pasar la noche con al menos 200.000
personas buscando refugio en el vip esta
ciudad se esfuerza por albergar y
alimentar a los desplazados las
autoridades piden ayuda a las
organizaciones internacionales
y necesitamos carpas más grandes para
poder ofrecer refugio tienen que estar
equipadas con cocinas e instalaciones
sanitarias adecuadas para que se pueda
cocinar allí la petición se produjo
cuando llegó al vive el primer lote de
suministros sanitarios
proporcionados por la o ms
este lugar nos servirá para recibir
suministros médicos que luego esperamos
podremos entregar a los centros de salud
de todo el país ya en los primeros días
hemos traído 36 toneladas métricas de
material médico destinado para tratar a
los heridos y realizar cirugías
pittsburgh it people and for food
service las autoridades temen que
cientos de miles de refugiados más se
vean obligados a buscar refugio en el
vip con la apertura de corredores
humanitarios de las zonas asediadas por
las fuerzas rusas